uh the most accurate count we have as of
this morning
are 64
kentuckians
remember this is fluid and the numbers
will change and sometimes they have
thank god gone down other times they've
gone up it breaks down as follows
20 in graves
13 in hopkins
11 in muhlenberg that's been reported as
well we believe it is struck 11
twelve and warren lives four eastern
caldwell counties one and at least
marshall eighteen counties taylor suffer
damage one in fulton
and one in lyon as of this morning
undoubtedly our best count for confirmed
there will be more
uh the most accurate count we believe
it'll certainly be above 70 or maybe
even 80.
but again with this amount of money this
is fluent in rubble and the numbers may
change and
breaks down as follows on the number of
lost lives in graves currently we
believe there are at least a hundred and
five kentuckians on account of
muhlenberg i think that's been reported
we are still it is working 11 defined 12
and warren currently we have 300
national guard assisting wrestling and
recovery experts a few more than the
taylor hundreds of state employees from
transportation capital one in lion the
division of forestry without hearing
roads
you know we saw a little light i hope
yesterday and we were actually able and
i believe it'll certainly be it may feel
about seven to get from just clearing
roads eighty just starting to haul with
this amount
i believe that's the same in muhlenberg
county for my conversation with the
judge
uh this morning
uh work directly
with groups to get cell service back in
hopkins uh
marshall
and i think it's up and going in fulton
county as well working on
um hickman
to recap we declared a state of
emergency
roughly midnight before midnight uh
before the
storm really hit
we received an immediate federal
emergency declaration i believe on
uh sunday which is the fastest we've
ever seen and last night
we received a federal declaration of
major emergency i think the fastest that
has ever been issued and we are really
grateful uh from fema graciashek is here
with us and is going to give us an
update on what that means but it's it's
really good news for our families it
means fema is going to be on the ground
uh documenting losses at people's homes
helping them go ahead and file uh their
claims again i believe this is the most
rapid response by the federal government
in the history of the united states of
america and we need it
um and we are really uh grateful for it
um
and then uh
michael dossett will go over
um
a few other things here in in a minute
uh
new
pieces out today and and i have a lot of
pieces of paper here i'm going to work
through them the best i can
is i'm ordering
flags to to half staff in honor
of
those lost and those suffering from this
tornado
so all state office buildings will be
lowered to half staff for one week in
honor of the kentuckians who
were killed
and or severely impacted
so they should be lowered beginning
at sunrise
tuesday december 14th and remain so
until sundown monday
december 20th
i'm asking businesses
other states to to join us
in the recognition of
our kentuckians who are struggling
so badly
next update some potential uh good news
from the candle factory in mayfield that
we are
actively working to confirm this
information all of this is being
reported
by the business we pray
that it is true
but we are
working to confirm it so according to
the business
110
individuals
94
are alive and have been accounted for
again we are working to confirm that
eight
are dead
we found
eight bodies
and eight are missing
we feared much much worse and again
i pray that it is it is accurate but
with no phones with 15 plus feet of
wreckage that had
a dozen backhoes trying to
to pull things off of it
there was no way at the time to know how
many individuals made it out so we very
much hope
that that is
true
we've opened up our state parks uh for
housing for impacted families pennyrial
is already full i think we have a
hundred plus adults um and a lot of kids
uh that are out there we're going to
guarantee at least two weeks
of stay there may be other options by
the end of that but we're not going to
let any of our folks go
homeless
we
currently have uh distressed families at
ken lake and kentucky dam village
uh
currently we have some openings i'm
working with the county judge
uh judge perry in in graves county uh to
move people from a warning
warming center or shelter
to these rooms we've got at least 58
rooms open at ken lake
kentucky dam village we have 30 open if
we can get power to lake barclay we'll
open up about 50
more
we do need a little bit of help
we need some volunteers
to help us staff the state park it'll be
things like washing dishes and washing
clothes but we could really uh use that
help so if you are looking uh for a
place to be of assistance
you can
contact director andy cassette
his name's andy at 502-418-3581
his email andy dot cassette
i k-a-s-i-t z at
k y dot gov
i hope he's flooded with calls
and emails and we can put as many people
to work helping our people out as
possible
just a few more
facts about those we've we've lost
18 are still
unidentified
of the ones that we know
the age
the age range
is five months
to 86 years
and six are younger than 18.
help keeps pouring in from all over the
country
thank you
to everyone we feel your love here in
kentucky
the
team kentucky team western kentucky
tornado relief fund
now 31
279 donations
over four million dollars uh raised into
it uh thus far
uh do we have the website those that um
[Music]
would like to help us that's team wky
relieffund.ky.gov
this is a fund associated with the state
and be fully transparent
on how it is spent there will be no
administrative fees taken out of it all
of it it's going to go to help these
families
today we're announcing the first
expenditure
from that
we're gonna be providing five thousand
dollars
in burial expenses
for each family
that has lost a loved one
we're gonna ask the funeral home or or
group helping out to not charge the
families beyond
that five thousand dollars um
we at least have to be able to grieve
together
and no one's going to have to apply
um we're going to work with our vital
statistics group
for everyone who's been identified and
we're going to work to reach out and
contact
those families
directly
right now we think we have about 30 000
kentucky homes that are without power
significant
debris removal
going on right now
um
but there's just a mountain of waste
it is going to take a significant amount
of time
um we've got significant livestock
um
dead in all of the areas there's there's
ongoing cleanup
with that too
um
department for community-based services
in
mayfield suffer damage cannot serve the
public at this time a mobile unit is in
process to get down there so it can
provide
those continuing needed services those
that have needs for the department for
community-based services can call
1-855-306-8959
or applying for help online through the
connect site
walgreens and mayfield it's the only
pharmacy that has been open
uh starting today walmart plans to open
for prescription fulfillment this is in
mayfield if you need a refill it help if
you can bring your medication bottles
but the pharmacy recognized that
you probably don't have them
so if you have a list of your
medications
that would be helpful too
mayfield nursing and rehab has been
closed due to storm damage and will need
to rebuild all residents
have been relocated
kentucky state police is asking
especially in the grace county area for
any family members of missing loved ones
you should report to the office building
of his house ministries to provide a
reference
to standard to a reference standard to
law enforcement for identification
purposes it's located at 1250 ky 303
in mayfield anybody who needs assistance
in getting there call 859-267-7775
kentucky state police is also using
rapid dna technology to assist in the
identification of victims so they're
requesting any family members of missing
loved ones to come to that same building
to submit dna so that they can
match
uh kentucky state police is also working
to verify
the information on the candle
factory
i know like the folks in in western
kentucky um
i'm not doing so well today and i'm not
sure how many of us uh are
i was
working on getting the confirmed
deaths this morning and realized i was
writing on the back of uh of notes that
one of my kids took from uh school
and here's what um
what it is
it's it's notes on inertia
it means that an object that's in motion
will stay
in motion
so we're going to keep putting one foot
in front of the other and push through
this
everybody out there get the help you
need
take care of yourself and we'll continue
to to provide updates um to the people
of western kentucky we're not going
anywhere
we're going to be with you today
we're going to be with you tomorrow and
and we're going to be there with you to
rebuild this is one state
of people that love one another
and
i think everybody in kentucky but also
everybody in the country
is is standing with you and with that
i'll turn it over to director dossa
thank you governor and good morning
so i'm giving going to give you an
overall update of operations the state
eoc is in operation at level three
we have an extraordinary complement of
state and federal personnel probably
numbering
80 to 100 right now these folks will be
on duty each day and every day including
the weekends
to answer the requests from our counties
and to render assistance
so we have representatives from the
kentucky transportation cabinet the
national guard
forestry law enforcement energy sector
sheltering volunteer organization parks
red cross we've established an aircraft
command and control section for
overflights to survey the damage
so now go into some of the power numbers
and
the governor there's been some good news
within the last 10 minutes the numbers
dropped again we are literally at 28 000
uh
i'm sorry 28
531
outages as of this moment
this is a remarkable outcome
when you look at the damage that has
been impacted across our commonwealth
so approximately 95 percent of
potentially impacted power lines have
been assessed that's a big thing in most
of these events the power companies
can't get to the lines even to perform
the assessments so 95 have been
completed
there's some bad news with the good news
there are still 29 transmission lines
these are the lines that feed from the
power uh power plants if you recall in
the ice storm you saw collapse of these
massive towers that run across our state
uh we have had that and the restoration
will be weeks to months for these so
we'll we'll have a small number that
feed off these transmission lines that
are still out
we have at least 97 power structures
damaged
several local power companies have
extensive damage to their own
distribution systems
and they're underway certainly
mutual aid crews from across other
states are arriving daily
we have and this is just an estimate of
three companies
and we have a number of them and i'll go
through them
we have 8 000
power poles these are the ones in your
neighborhood that are down
they have to be dug replaced wire strung
so it's a massive effort
eight of the most impacted local power
companies west kentucky rural electric
cooperative lexington electric nashville
electric memphis light gas and water
warren rural electric murray electric
bowling green municipal municipality
and mayfield electric
so we have uh
water systems also impacted three
systems currently not not operational
with 10 400 customers
11 systems currently without with
limited operational capabilities for
about 17 000 customers these are boil
water advisories we're certainly
familiar with those in other impacts
the division continues to coordinate
with all municipal utilities
we are delivering
generators as we speak we uh
our regional administrator will speak to
some of the uh
the the generation
opportunities and things they're
bringing over target here
in a second
in graves uh in in mayfield um they're
experiencing overload uh in some
circuits and that's
that is to be expected uh because of the
level of power that they're trying to uh
restore generators arrived at the mills
nursing and rehabilitation this morning
and they've restored heat
we're coordinating with fema the u.s
corps of engineers and department of
public health to provide water
certainly wasn't
in high demand in mayfield and in other
communities
we are bulk drop shipping water bottled
water to
to command centers across the state in
the impact area
we have requested and received
and again folks i can't stress
the amount of federal support that came
so quickly
i can tell you uh from just being a
a veteran of now 17 disasters it takes
time to get wheels rolling
we had usar teams these are federal
urban search and rescue teams on the
ground before i had finished submitting
the request
graciasheck just overnight approved
three additional
usar teams to do wide area searches we
we're doing the uh the known impact and
now we have to search all of the debris
areas
the forward elements of those teams
arrived last night when they were
requested yesterday so
folks pulling out all the stops in
hopkins we're assisting providing
generations of dawson springs
independent school that's a key issue
that was assessed last night and we'll
have something on the way
in dawson springs
obviously electric is still
down and water is being reestablished
verizon also set some mobile cellular
units in place last night
so with that
restoration is ongoing this again is not
going to be a week or a month operation
folks uh this will go on for
years to come this is a massive event
the largest uh income the largest and
most devastating in kentucky's history
and i'll close with saying
the key here is our thoughts and prayers
and our hearts go out to all of the
victims
to all of the families and to the
families of those who are still missing
this is a horrific event and prayers
will help
now i'll introduce gracious check gracia
was with the governor and i yesterday
as we again toured the area with
the secretary of dhs um
alejandro
mayorkas it's always a challenge to
pronounce the secretary's name
and
also uh gracias uh uh immediate
boss the fema administrator dan criswell
these were remarkable folks i spent the
day with them the governor uh was with
them
uh they get it and they care and gracia
in syncing with uh administrator uh
criswell and secretary
marcus
had our application all the way to the
white house with approvals
waiting for the signed document and
that's how quick this thing moves so
thank you gracia and please update us on
fema
governor director dawson thank you uh
yesterday meant so much to the secretary
to the administrator to really see and
as they said the pictures
didn't do anything what we saw on the
ground and such an impact
and as director das had said our our
hearts and prayers and thoughts go to
the families for the families who lost
loved ones for the families who suffered
such incredible damages from what we saw
and last night as you heard the
president did declare a major
declaration and this included eight
counties and i'll read those counties
off
it is for caldwell
fulton graves hopkins
marshall muhlenberg taylor and warren
counties
and that's just the beginning
we will work with the state on
identifying other counties to get them
added on
what this is what this means is that
there is assistance for individuals
for homeowners
for renters
they need to apply for fema assistance
the administrator did say yesterday the
first line of defense is insurance
make sure if you have insurance that is
your you've already called them
but
we also encourage everyone to apply for
fema assistance
and that comes in various ways and i
know we've given the slide
to
the governor's office so we'll make sure
that gets out there into the media
you can go to the app you can apply
online
at disaster assistance i'll probably
make it easier i'm sorry
disaster assistance dot gov
one word disaster assistance dot gov
or you can call the fema hotline at
1-800-621
fema
and that's 1-800-621-3362
we will have people out
there disaster survivor assistance teams
they're going to be out in the those
counties that have been declared and
they'll we may even have people as soon
as today um i i will get an update of
that but you'll see them they'll be in
fema shirts they'll have a fema id and
they'll be carrying an ipad they're
going to go door-to-door they're going
to go where they see people working on
their homes and try to get them
registered and making sure that they're
already into that system and a person
will receive a nine digit number
and they can they need to make sure they
keep that number because they can keep
going back online and checking their
registration and the status of that
so
you know don't hesitate when you see a
fema person with fema id come up to you
and and talk with them because you may
also be able to tell them where we may
find other survivors uh to bring that
assistance to them and get them
registered
that is the key message today
of that is to register register register
in any one of those three ways
and there's going to be various forms of
assistance available
to those that are eligible
and that's in forms of a low-interest
loan with a small business
administration
to grants which we could include
temporary housing rental assistance
repairs
other needs assistance such as medical
we heard
people lost their prescriptions
dental
and funeral assistance
so again i encourage everybody to
register
and when you register
what one thing is important is to make
sure
you give a number of where you can be
reached you may be staying with family
and friends you may have lost your cell
phone
make sure you give a number of where you
can be reached because a housing
inspector will be reaching out to you
so that's the disaster assistance piece
now what came along with the major
declaration for those eight counties is
also category a they were counties were
already declared for category b which
was emergency protective measures over
time things that you did in times of the
storms
for the police the first responders the
vehicles they used but also it was
available for debris clearance pushing
debris off to the roadside
now they have received debris category a
which is debris debris clearance or
debris removal
that is the actual removal of debris
that they may be eligible to be
reimbursed up to 75 percent by the
federal government
so i know we spoke about it yesterday i
encourage those public officials to
document document document
um we we will have people out on the
ground we have
fema people army corps of engineer
people out on the ground doing debris
surveys they're linking up with the
local entities to help guide them
through what they need to do but also
looking at possibly private property
debris removal demolition i know that's
a lot of questions that are going to be
asked so we'd like to get those answers
as quickly as possible so everything is
done the right way so that it could be
eligible
and then also we have subject matter
experts looking at
the water and wastewater
systems to see what we can do for
emergency repairs because we know it's
important to get those up and running so
we will be working with the locals and
state and again all of this is in
support of the state they are locked
tight with us it is there's no shadows
between us so that's what we're doing
and as director das had spoke about yes
we have four urban search and rescue
teams on the ground
one being at the candle factory where
the three others are in graves county
and they're doing the primary and
secondary searches they've already begun
those this morning and you'll see mobile
emergency response support vehicles
supporting all of these field elements
and the communities with communications
and helping them in the short-term need
for communications
we have housing experts on the ground
today because that's a big question also
we know that there's going to be a need
for housing it's how we get there
together because we know kentucky's
resilient and we need to work together
to get to housing and we're going to
strategize with the state on this and
this is for both short and long-term
housing and then in regards to
commodities we have water meals cots and
blankets for 15 000 people per day and
we continue to move trucks in every day
and then as was discussed we have
additional water that's already been
delivered
in director dosset
we together have been able to do
assessments for generators and provide
generators to critical public places so
again it's a great partnership that you
know
we are here to support the state in any
of their needs and we will continue to
be here so thank you again governor
all right um we'll open it up to
questions we've got
five
that are uh
here with us today five journalists and
and others on the line so we'll start
with georgia macarthur
okay we'll go to carolina
governor
your voice is shaking this morning
you nearly broke down you were
announcing some of the ages
how are you feeling how are the people
of western kentucky feeling the one
thing
how is everyone doing
i mean
people of western kentucky have gone
through an unspeakable trauma i mean
it's it's it's traumatic
you can be in there helping um
you go from
grief to shock to
being resolute
span of 10 minutes and and and then you
go back um
it's hard to understand how something
like this or why something like this
happens it is just awful
um
and the people who lost everything
but are still here with us it's it's
it's hard to think of them as lucky but
um
it
this is really hard
um but we're gonna make it um
we put one foot in front of the other
make sure we have the inertia
and
we'll rebuild there's going to be
grief um there's going to be cleanup
but then we're going to make sure that
that everybody gets back on their feet
we do have a lot of support out there i
mean the whole country uh is calling and
trying to help actually one of the
biggest challenges we have in these
counties is
too much in many ways how to coordinate
um an unprecedented amount of of goods
and of volunteers um
and you know but but uh there's a lot of
love out there
bill
we've heard that the president um is
coming to kentucky and we are working to
coordinate a visit we don't have any
details uh yet um about it um but uh uh
president biden called me three times on
saturday um
and and
you know has has has moved faster than
than we've ever seen on on on getting us
the the aid we need we will welcome him
here we will thank him uh for his help
and
sadly we'll show him the
worst tornado damage imaginable
certainly the worst in uh in our history
uh tom thank you governor
three quick ones um you i'm gonna have
more kentucky guard numbers uh activated
uh with the housing the fema helps with
would i include the the trailers that we
remember like from the katrina and what
have you and can you for clarification
explain what a reference standard is
most people don't understand what that
is about dna is the photos
oh so so they're going to need
kentucky state police if you're missing
a loved one are going to need
information photos um
whatever you can bring about your loved
one that would help identify
them i'd bring you know as much as you
can and then they're gonna take a dna
sample from you if you were related to
them
probably for the worst case of
of the worst and we still have
unidentified
uh bodies
uh we will call out as many national
guard as are needed um we in in many
ways it's it's almost limitation by
equipment
right uh because what is needed um there
is still
uh search and rescue going on but at
some point that will switch to
uh
debris removal um we're assisting in
some
law enforcement capacities but as power
gets back up that'll probably change too
um if we need more we'll have more um
and then what was the last one oh fema
uh
so fema housing um is is an ongoing uh
conversation we want to make sure that
we get the most effective form i think
there's uh rvs i think that there are
um you know the the type that that you
referenced um
one thing fema's learned about us though
is um we take care of us
and um
people have opened up their homes
already every time a house
has power that comes back on it's not
just one family that's going to it it's
them and and all their friends and maybe
somebody they met just the day before
um
[Music]
well it's it's too early and where we
are to um
to know any changes
uh that ought to be made in the in the
future i i believe that this is gonna
end up being an e5
tornado which
you can have the warnings but
what do you do right
um
the homes that sit if you haven't been
down there it
they didn't take the roof off that's
what we're used to seeing with tornadoes
right that if you get to your safe place
you're safe you get to the basement
you're safe
there's no safe place when you get hit
by by something like this i'm sure that
we will look
at what procedures
the facility had uh that's that's that's
that's natural but um
it's still too early and we may well
have to live
with the idea that some storms are so
powerful
um
that that
that
what we can do to protect ourselves is
is is limited
um
i really hope the information is correct
and is verified because of
94 folks um
are safe and accounted for that's that's
the miracle we've been hoping for for a
couple of days very first place i went
was that factory and and
the 94 must have been folks that had
left
um
because it's hard to imagine um
surviving once it hit
jeff one more thank you okay today
one year ago we watched arrived to
kentucky
one year later
your thoughts right now with what's
going on
with conductance it's it's just it's
it's it's hard um
we've had a pandemic
the last two years we've had a historic
ice storm we had flooding that had some
of our eastern kentucky towns underwater
and and and now we have this
we'll push through all of it because we
don't have a choice
and we're strong enough to do it
john boyle wfpl
hi governor um i wanted to speak uh
specifically about the candle factory
obviously that's that's a big uh big
development if it does turn out to be
true
um and i know you guys are working on
confirming it but i wanted to get a
sense from you um you know how confident
the state is in that information um at
this point in the process
uh and then a little bit of i guess uh
specific details on the ways you guys
are working through it to to verify that
this information is correct
so we we're verifying the information so
i don't i don't have a level of of of
confidence yet um this is information
provided directly by the company uh
kentucky state police is is working
through the list of individuals they
found we just want to
make sure they are okay and then we need
um
we need to to proof whatever whatever
documentation it would take to establish
um the number of people who who were
there that we have to account for we
believe it's 110 we just want to make
sure so
um i can't give you a level of
confidence but but this is the
information the company's providing and
so i want to provide it
to the public and and very much hope
that it's true i think the company has
also pledged um to cover funeral
expenses of of of their families
uh jack brammer from the herald leader
governor of the 64 people confirmed dead
do you know how many have been
identified
and have the 105 kentuckians unaccounted
for do you have a county by county
breakdown of
those folks
i don't have a county by county
breakdown with me now
we will work on on getting that and
remember that's fluid
because people have to report somebody
as as as missing
so
18
of the 64 to my knowledge are
unidentified so i'm
not going to try to do math up here but
um but if you do the subtraction there
you'll you'll get the the identify
identification
uh wdrb
no okay uh
newsie
nope okay uh corinne boyer
hi governor um your office put out a
warning friday afternoon about the
weather
that was to hit on friday evening do we
know what kind of warning people at the
kindle factory received
well the information was absolutely out
in the public about a strong set of of
storms
that could produce tornadoes we knew we
were going to have
a significant weather event
but you can stand in the middle of
mayfield and
i don't think i don't think
i don't think anyone
could have predicted something as
devastating as as as this is
um i do believe there were warnings i
believe for days
uh people were advised um
i i don't fault warning systems i don't
fault training
i don't know about the the procedures in
the in the in the candle factory and
don't have any
any reason to fault that either i mean
how do you tell people that there's
going to be one of the most powerful
tornadoes in history and it's going to
come directly through
your building
it's another reason it just makes it
really hard
it's the
the why is an answer that um
that we'll get one day
but not one that i think that we'll get
on this earth
debbie yetter courier journal
hi governor i'm here um i wanted to ask
in terms of the candle factory have the
owners been cooperating or coordinating
with emergency authorities
and uh ultimately whose responsibility
is it for establishing the deaths i
presume they aren't the official
person to do that and finally is the
search and rescue still going on at the
uh candle factory and what are you all
finding
so the owners
made several contacts yesterday
including to
my office we put them in touch we stand
in the room um with the with the
coordinators there on the ground um the
the company does
know or should know right who was there
who who works for them and so they're an
integral part
of being able to to contact folks and
and remember
you couldn't contact folks
for for a significant period of of time
in fact i was working with at t directly
yesterday that got three different
uh uh counties up that had been entirely
uh out and it's really hard to do search
and rescue to to help to to communicate
with each other
without it uh the kentucky state police
is the group that's currently verifying
uh the information and once that's
verified it it will become official
um
again
really hope i really hope it's real
um remember there's still a
if if the company's
information is correct there's still at
least eight unidentified individuals so
that operation is continuing
uh
right now it's it's pretty much two
12-hour shifts one uh uh louisville and
one lexington are managing um they sent
down some incredible folks uh well
trained for it uh they're coordinating
with mayfield's fire chief both fire
chief and police chief in mayfield
are doing a phenomenal job
um police chief talked yesterday about
how he had to take time to figure out
which of his officers have homes anymore
that they've been running for 36 hours
before
they could breathe and say do you have
any place to go home to
uh to to rest um but they the the fire
chief specifically wanted to thank
lexington and louisville
and so many others out there but the
mayors of both those towns have reached
out have said what do you need
uh put them in direct contact with with
others um
but but everybody out there i mean when
when i was in dalston
most of volunteers were from
madisonville which had been spared and
and and had come to
uh to help
uh
bellissimo from fox 17.
amanda yeah okay amanda macias for cnbc
hi thank you so much for doing this i
wanted to ask about the initial cost
assessments for the damage to your state
and if you think you have enough of the
financial assistance or you may
potentially need more
and my second question um are there any
big businesses or corporations that have
reached out and pitched in
oh there are so many i i i'm i almost
want to say that every business uh has
called or or or tried to call um i had
voicemail from the ceo amazon i i guess
he's the ceo of amazon he can find my
number
um uh at his first name's andy who knew
um but but all over and it's it's
actually really hard to process the
requests when it's it's wild when you
have like a fortune 50 company and and
you say i'll make that call back when
when i can um
the love has been
unbelievable
um
and i guess that's that's what keeps you
going both from your neighbors and and
and the rest um
i i don't have yet an estimate on
damages but it's in the hundreds of
millions of dollars at least um
i said this yesterday there's there is
not a lens
big enough to capture
the devastation and everybody who's come
in from fema and homeland have said the
the the same you
you stand in the middle of mayfield or
or dawson where two-thirds of the town
are gone or or in that town of
muhlenberg county and
it's almost crushing
um
how it how it how it how it feels
but again
um whatever the cost i know our federal
partners are there with us um we will
spare no expense uh by the state i'm
gonna spend as much of today as i can
ensuring whether it's state parks or
others that we've got a warm place for
our families to sleep
and then
turn in
tomorrow or the next day i'm going to
make sure that we come together to make
sure these families can celebrate
christmas too
we've lost some kids
and we have some kids that lost their
homes
and at this time of year especially as a
person of faith i want to make sure that
we can be there for them and i know now
i said that there's going to be another
uh
round of support that comes out there
all right um i appreciate it
oh karen czar
karen last question because this is
about all i can do
thanks governor i apologize i actually
have to uh thank you to you and thank
you for your team for getting us info so
quickly over the weekend
um first to citizens who want to go in
and help i know you had said it's best
for people to stay away but are there
any types of expertise where it would be
a help and not a hindrance and then the
second question is
uh
obviously this also brings out the worst
in people we've seen some of the best
but how do you identify and report scams
thank you
uh well
identify and report uh scams both
locally
the attorney general's office i know has
also pledged its support the price
gouging statute is in effect that's also
the attorney general's office so report
to them if all of a sudden gas goes
through the roof or building materials
uh go through the roof uh sadly we have
seen that uh
sometimes
but i
i hope that we won't see it here a
tragedy of this level hopefully no one
um will will try to take advantage of
what was her other
what was what was the other question
karen
oh um well first we do need help at our
state parks um uh and you know that
doesn't take any expertise at all just
uh chipping in and and and helping uh to
do the things that that support these
families
i believe right now that that the
expertise that is needed is is there
all right uh tell our folks in western
kentucky uh stay strong to the rest of
kentucky now if it hurts it's it's
because you care
uh to all of you we love you uh we're
gonna be with you today tomorrow and in
the years to come
you